[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
bienvenue dans ce journal du lundi 21
octobre voici les titres une cure de
jouvence pour le quartier du val hibou à
plaisir d'ici 2027 il sera entièrement
reconfigurer le plan de rénovation a été
présenté aux habitants samedi
transformation évalué à 65 millions
d'euros
elle souhaite sa sauvegarde
l'association des amis des forêts de
versailles a envoyé une lettre au préfet
des yvelines l'objectif demandé le
classement du massif en forêt de
protection explication avec son
président au plateau et puis l'open de
france de golf s'est clôturé hier à
saint quentin en yvelines victoire du
belge nicolas colsaerts sur le green de
l'albatros ce résultat et d'autres
encore à suivre dans cette édition et on
parle à la fin de ce journal aussi de ce
projet qui se constitue à magny les
hameaux
une unité de transformation lainière une
première assemblée générale se dérouler
samedi
[Musique]
la mutation du vally bout continue les
habitants du quartier plaisir oies ont
découvert ce week-end le nouveau projet
national de renouvellement urbain
réorganisation des lieux rénovation des
intérieurs ou encore intégration des
enjeux écologiques le point sur le
dossier avec marylène iapichino et
mélanie poker une transformation en
profondeur le quartier du valais bout va
changer de visage dans les années à
venir un nouveau projet de rénovation
urbaine va le mener notamment à devenir
un éco quartier
on va essayer de mettre en application
toutes les nouvelles normes et toutes
les nouvelles lois sur justement le
développement vous savez durable sur
l'énergie donc et puis surtout les
espaces verts et débuté en 2005 le
projet se voit doté d'une enveloppe de
65 millions d'euros services sociaux
regroupés création d'un garage solidaire
de liaisons douces et réorganisation du
quartier 56 logements vont être détruits
600 autres rénovés en même temps qu'on
remet à neuf les logements notre
ambition c'est aussi de repenser la vie
le fonctionnement du quartier
la circulation en voiture le
stationnement des voitures l'arrivée
nouveaux équipements publics des
services publics donc mais aussi
pourquoi pas des services marchands
c'est pas seulement comme on croit des
problèmes de sécurité c'est des
problèmes de qualité du bâti
de qualité de la circulation pour
pouvoir venir jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
tranquille mans pour pouvoir avoir des
endroits où les enfants jouent dehors
pour pouvoir avoir une grande qualité
scolaire pour les enfants
porté par la ville le département la
région ile-de-france et le bailleur les
résidents civils et seul le projet sera
pensé avec les habitants située en plein
centre-ville le vélib ou accueille
quatre mille personnes
ça fait une ouverture vers le haut du
quartier mais l'axé ça sera facile
c'était un bon des discussions déjà
important poteau de quartier
notre sécurité la rénovation intérieure
des immeubles doit commencer au début de
l'année 2020 de nouveaux logements en
accession à la propriété doivent aussi
voir le jour
une transformation pensée sur les huit
années à venir
autre projet phare du côté de guyancourt
c'est la rénovation du maïdo sol après
deux ans de chantier cet aménagement
fait peau neuve
une voix unique entouré de végétation
qui a été inaugurée samedi marylène
iapichino et nicolas landry c'est une
des artères principales de guyancourt le
mail des sols a connu une période de
rénovation une nouvelle voie piétonne de
nouvelles plantations des espaces de
jeux pour les enfants un projet
municipal lancée en 2014
je trouve que c'est vraiment une très
belle rénovation parce que nous habitons
depuis 30 ans dans le quartier donc on a
connu l'ancien mal my vraiment je trouve
que c'est très réussi
j'aime beaucoup cet endroit parce que je
trouve que c'est aéré pour les enfants
je trouve que c'est une bonne idée est
effectivement d'avoir rassemblé 2 chemin
qui était avant de part et d'autre en un
seul fait plus de luminosité et plus de
déplacements doux au faciles sont sans
gêne sans rien du tout
l'idée de ce projet remplacer les saules
malades datant des années 70
le chantier a commencé en juillet 2018
deux entreprises et leurs sous-traitants
ont travaillé sur leurs vêtements et les
plantations
dix sept mille mètres carrés de surface
réaménager un investissement de plus de
2 millions d'euros pour guyancourt cette
voie verte qui permet la cohabitation
entre les piétons les cyclistes les
familles avec poussettes hawks et c'est
avant tout ce revêtement aussi en granit
d'excellente qualité
et puis effectivement ces espaces verts
qui ont été recréés avec énormément
d'essence nouvelles et notamment des
essences de sol le long du mall on
retrouve des saules donc des grands sol
en taille
très importante puisque certains sont
sept mètres de haut au final ce projet a
abouti à travers des concertations avec
les riverains
une concertation justifiée par la
contestation de certains habitants à
propos de l'abattage des arbres et cette
association se bat justement pour la
sauvegarde des arbres ceux de la forêt
domaniale de versailles plus de 1000
hectares répartis sur la cité royale
aussi à vélizy en passant par et
guyancourt et jouy en josas notamment
bonsoir pire desnos président de
l'association à des amis des forêts de
versailles et de fausses reposez vous
êtes également historien local notamment
de ces deux massifs qui sont à cheval
sur les yvelines et le département des
hauts-de-seine
vous avez transmis tout récemment une
lettre au préfet des yvelines pour
demander le classement de la forêt de
versailles la forêt domaniale en forêt
de protection déjà qu'est ce qu'on
appelle la forêt de versailles sur
quelle partie elle s'étend cette forêt
la forêt de versailles
comme vous l'avez dit c'est un peu plus
de 1000 ha vu un peu moins évidemment
fort est proprement dit elle elle se
situe au sud de versailles
c'est qu'une forêt qui a été comment
dirais-je aménagé déjà à l'époque de
louis xiv que c'était la forêt de louis
xiv
l aujourd'hui elles touchent cette
commune on vient de voir la carte elle
est très morcelé cette fois et
finalement c'est plusieurs massifs voilà
alors oui dans ces bas plusieurs massifs
en fait c'est un seul massif qui a été
grignotée m avec le temps alors de le le
premier grignotage donc un qui remonte
au moyen-age c'est le plateau de satory
le deuxième qui a commencé au moyen âge
mais qui a été très rapidement amplifié
c'est le golf de la boulie maintenant
qu'a pris plus de 100 hectares donc
petit à petit les aménagements les les
l'urbanisme à grignoter tout doucement
cette cette forêt que vous parliez du
lien avec l'histoire louis xiv ya
forcément un domaine qui jouxte cette
forêt c'est le château de versailles il
ya un lien avec ce domaine fatalement
puisque c'est comme je ne le dira
c'était c'est le
la forêt par définition 2014 elle était
d'ailleurs avec toute cette partie là
pratiquement était et est incluse dans
le grand parc du château fin 2014
c'était la foire où il allait chasser
veut prioritairement c'est ce qui assure
un peu moins qu'elle louis 15 licences
mais quand même toujours
donc c'est effectivement un endroit
patrimonial qui a une très forte
histoire et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
conserver déjà cela et puis il ya
aujourd'hui des décidé d'aider des lieux
remarquables ou tout simplement au
pouvoir la région le château et donc il
ya des vraies richesses sur place des
richesses aussi naturel on imagine des
richesses naturelles déjà le ya une
partie d'ailleurs dû du massif qui est
plus ou moins protégés par le par la
vallée de la bièvre les amis de la belle
hélène vallée de la bièvre ont réussi à
faire protéger donc toute la vallée de
la bière c'est à l'intérieur de la forêt
et donc je pense qu'il est grand temps
maintenant compte tenu des aménagements
en cours
il est grand temps de de fixer l'avenir
pas le présent le présent c'est clair il
va y avoir du grignotage un petit peu
encore il faut l'accepter c'est le
développement de la société et des
besoins mais il va falloir et c'est ce
que le message que j'essaie de faire
passer auprès des élus et pas seulement
il va falloir pérenniser ce qui reste
penser aux générations futures voilà
parce que c'est tout simplement c'est un
cetain bien absolument indispensable
mais ce qui m'a donc générations futures
sur le passé un si vous voulez en savoir
davantage
lien un livre 1 qui a été publiée par
vous votre association c'est cet ouvrage
qui est à retrouver on le retrouve sur
notamment le site internet de
l'association qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran alors juste pour revenir du coup
sûr la démarche aujourd'hui à des vrais
risques vous le disiez des grignotages
un peu à droite à gauche des deux
finalement l'urbanisme qui prend le
dessus sur sur cette forêt aujourd'hui
elle est traversée de part en part par
la nationale 12 on peut
la 186 ça il ya la rd 91 qui va
traverser toutes les photos de satory là
il ya un projet qui nous a d'ailleurs un
petit peu interpellé depuis quelques
années parce que depuis 2005 avait un
projet d'aménagement de la rd 91 en
grand rond-point à l'époque et vinrent
acté la forêt quand même de deux
hectares et demi alors sur eux vous
allez me dire deux hectares et demi qu
est-ce que c'est sur mille ha oui mais
c'est comme ça petit appétit à chaque
fois qu'on prend on prend entité tard
par ci inquiète hectares par là le poids
qu'ils allaient aussi la voie
ferroviaire qui passe un peu plus un peu
plus bas donc on voit bien que que tout
ça ça a été grignotée avec le temps et
puis il ya le le projet du plateau de
satory
et là aussi on est un petit peu
interpellé parce que l'aménageur dans
son dans la définition son périmètre
prévoit la forêt le rebond nous ont dit
non ça bah ça marche pas ça va pas
marcher comme ça il faut absolument a
même aménagé en étant le plus
parcimonieux possible le plus ambitieux
possible minutieux possible pour
justement préserver les espaces naturels
parce qu'ils doivent rentrer les espaces
naturels dans les dans les projets
urbains
il doit y avoir un équilibre entre le
bâti et le naturel cs4 assez bien
compris je le pense et c'est en tout cas
dans sa dans sa démarche
françois de mazières le maire de
versailles et justement qu'est ce que ça
changerait le fait que cette fois ci
votre démarche aboutit que cette forêt
soit classé en forêt de protection ça
change quoi concrètement alors ça change
rien fondamentalement si ce n'est que le
foncier le foncier de la forêt est
protégé d'accord c'est à dire on peut
plus prendre des parcelles de forêts
pour qu'ils augmentent est un cimetière
qui faire une installation sportive qui
pour faire un petit kit pilotis cement
et c'est ça c'est fini
le la protection en pense qu'on viennent
grignoter à nouveau ça veut pas dire
qu'on ne peut pas le feu
et remet le la procédure administrative
sera plus on y arrive est très compliqué
et très long parce que c'est le conseil
d'état qui va valider la protection et
l'ia que le conseil d'état qui peut
lever la protection donc dès l'instant
où il y a un projet il faut que le
conseil d'état donne son aval est ce que
le fait que tout ça est ce que le préfet
vous a répondu aujourd'hui ce que c'est
lui qui déclenchera cette procédure
voilà c'est le sait le préfet en fait la
procédure est toujours été comme ça
puisque on a une petite expérience quand
même dans la procédure de classement
c'est nous qui avions initié genou je
veux dire notre association qui à
l'époque était présidée par je peux pas
or et puis ensuite par la chute ce qui
est aujourd'hui sénateur des yvelines et
donc on a suivi pendant 15 ans la la la
la procédure de protection de fausses
reposes en fait c'est souvent les
associations qui saisissent le préfet
qui lui va saisir le ministre
agriculture qui lui va demander à la ddt
de préparer le dossier donc c'est lui
qui enclenche le processus c'est lui qui
va appuyer sur le bouton si j'ose dire
donc nous lui demandons simplement
appuyer sur le bouton de la protection
qui ne va pas arriver tout de suite et
c'est dur lentille 100 je veux
simplement dire que il faut absolument
rassurer tous les tous les élus les
maires parce qu'évidemment ils sont un
peu inquiète je dise oh là là on va peut
pouvoir bouger
s'ils vont pouvoir bouger la protection
d'abord ça va durer la procédure une
dizaine d'années pas à moins on aurait
la chance si c'est un peu moins et on
pourra la suivre on arrive déjà la fin
de cet entretien en tout cas on pourra
suivre toute l'évolution sur votre site
internet ou java ou quand les
internautes ont compressé jusque ya
l'office national des forêts notamment
qui vous a apporté son soutien dans
cette démarche et vous parlez aussi du
soutien de nombreux élus de non réélu
avec eux au début un petit une petite
interrogation de la part de françois de
mazières donc le maire de versailles et
président des gp il dit
vous voulez aller et je lui ai expliqué
il avait très bien vu que c'était
démarche plutôt raisonnable lui même est
assez sombre si vos questions d'écologie
de nature donc il a une madone il a
donné son appui
alain schmitt évidemment peut pas faire
autrement c'est ken au président en dix
ans les nombreux soutiens on arrive à la
fin de cet entretien merci à perdre et
c'est moi qui vous remercie le président
de l'association des amis des forêts de
versailles et de fo se repose merci 300
participants se sont mobilisés pour ce
challenge sportif et solidaire la
cinquième édition des marcassins du
coeur s'est déroulée en fin de semaine
dernière à guyancourt 1 depuis les
locaux de sodexo là où était donné le
départ trois parcours étaient proposés
aux salariés pendant leur pause déjeuner
retour avec manon varaldo la joélette
est prête pour accueillir lise 40 ans
atteint d'arthrogrypose une maladie
congénitale
elle se manifeste par des raideurs au
niveau de différentes articulations
c'est une maladie qui paralyse
donc les articulations pendant le
développement des foetus et en fait ça
restreint le développement musculaire et
articulaire
on a des limitations différentes selon
selon les personnes pour cette cinquième
édition les marcassins du coeur
organisent cette course solidaire en son
honneur en départ du siège sodexo de
guyancourt
il existe trois parcours le parcours de
marche le parcours de course à pied de 8
km c'est notre course que nous allons
faire aujourd'hui d'ailleurs et le
parcours de trail un 10 km avant de
débuter la course un échauffement
s'impose certains participants étaient
déguisés les frais d'inscription d'un
montant de 15 euros sont reversés à
trois associations
on a une récurrente ces des restos du
coeur les restos du coeur des
clayes-sous-bois c'est notre partenaire
depuis là depuis le début de la première
édition
ensuite on effectivement on choisit deux
autres associations qui n'ont pas
forcément pignon sur rue comme connaît
pas forcément là c'est l'argent pays
comtois et la tarentaise n'est pas la
ceinture bouclée lise maman de trois
enfants est prêt pour un parcours de 8
km à bord de sa joélette en fauteuil
tout terrain 270 participants munis de
leurs dossards se sont mobilisés voit le
fait que ce soit ça soit une pour une
oeuvre caritative me suis dit je parle
beaucoup de courses donc j'aime bien
aussi payer des courses ou où l'argent
va quelque part dutil en attendant le
retour des coureurs 40 bénévoles dont
alain s'occupe de l'approvisionnement
grâce à
aux dons de nos fournisseurs et
partenaires donc nous avons plus d'une
dizaine de fournisseurs qui chaque année
nous propose des produits
les participants ont pu se ravitailler
après la course elle s'est déroulée
pendant leur pause déjeuner pour sa
première participation ce coureur a
effectué 8 km et sur l'a été avec nous
c'est génial un peu un peu glissant un
peu mouillé sur le deuxième lac sur une
partie du parcours non je fais très
attention de ne pas glisser
avec cette cinquième édition les
marcassins du coeur ont reversé près de
4000 euros aux associations le sport on
part tout de suite du côté du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
son troisième open de france et à s'est
achevée ce dimanche avec la victoire du
belge nicolas colsaerts les français eux
terminent dans le top 20 revivez la
dernière journée de la compétition avec
michael et me d'euros dernier jour de
compétition de cet open de france 2019
ce dimanche 20 octobre
nicolas colsaerts dispose de trois coups
d'avancé avant d'aborder le dernier tour
le golf le reste le favori du public
c'est un franco belge s'est peut-être
nichols art
on verra on verra il a du mal il admet
tout le monde a du mal aujourd'hui les
pronostics qui se sont avérées justes
nicolas colsaerts remporté au trou
numéro 18 cette édition 2010 9 son
premier titre depuis sept ans le golfeur
termine 12 coups sous le par avec un
coup d'avancé
en conférence de presse le franco belge
de 36 ans vit ce moment avec sa famille
via son téléphone
c'est énormément de joueurs
voilà ça fait ça fait 18 ans que je suis
pro j'ai gagné deux fois j'aurais dû
gagner plus souvent comme je l'aï déjà
dit souvent elle fait de gagner chez
vous c'est génial j'ai joué un peu
l'impression de faire partie du paysage
golfique français de leur côté les
français n'ont une fois de plus pas
réussi à dompter ce parcours de
l'albatros les chefs de file de la
délégation française victor perez et
benjamin hebert termine 16e c'est un
parcours que je connais bien qui me
résiste souvent a donc cette année je
suis content parce que j'ai quand même
réussi à faire une bonne semaine
on les attend évidemment toujours encore
plus haut dans le leaderboard
mais indéniablement c'est une bonne
année pour le golf français sur le
european tour avec victor perez qui
la tête là du camp français actuellement
talonnée par benjamin hebert on n'oublie
pas également les jeunes pousses comme
romain jean gasc ou encore michael
lorenzo-vera cette 103e édition de
l'open de france de golf s'achève ici
sur le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
rendez vous l'année prochaine du 2 au 5
juillet à 2020 et pour revivre les
quatre jours d' open de france retrouvez
le sujet complet ce soir dans l'émission
à 7,8 sport sur tv 78 une émission
présentée par vous ou michele demi
d'euros bonsoir on ne jouait pas que sur
les greens ce week-end aussi dans les
gymnases avec du handball vous allez
nous parler du championnat de nationale
3 c'est ça un choc dans la lutte pour le
maintien plaisir
recevez l'équipe de bois ni à l'occasion
de la 4e journée
deux équipes qui comptabilisait
seulement une victoire depuis le début
de la saison
après une première période équilibrée
les deux formations regagnent les
vestiaires et au coude à coude 14 à 13
pour les visiteurs à la mi-temps en
deuxième période des plaisirs war
reviennent avec de meilleures intentions
et creuse l'écart le tableau d'affichage
indique un + 5 en faveur du club local
après 11 minutes de jeu mais plaisir se
fait peur elle emporte finalement d'un
petit but 25-24 on écoute le capitaine
de l'équipe falloir réitérer ce genre de
performance parce que je pense que ça va
pas nous sourire à chaque fois si on
joue comme ça
mais bon je pense que là on a passé une
semaine d'entraînement qu'était un peu
n'est pas au niveau d'une équipe de
nationale 3 ça se voit sur le terrain
donc je leur ai dit on en voit un genre
un petit message au passage il va
falloir qu'on se remette vite au boulot
parce que les grosses grosses équipes
arrivées on a besoin de points après
cette deuxième victoire en deux matches
plaisir grimpe au classement les
plaisirs oies sont dans le ventre mou à
la 7e place
donc j'ai dit voilà saison c'est
d'engranger le plus de matches de
l'année dernière
on est sauvé sans un changement de
règlement donc là c'est gagné le plus de
matches pour se redonner confiance et
peut-être le plus haut possible
après voilà on à équilibrer le bilan 2
victoires 2 défaites
on va faire en sorte que le bilan ils
sont positifs prochain match pour le
plaisir handball club le samedi de
novembre sur le teint de mussy à pontenx
une autre équipe qui devrait jouer le
maintien à cette saison une fin de série
à présent michael en football les
invincibles de versailles sont tombés ce
week-end sur le terrain à 2 saint leu
après 20 matches sans défaite sur deux
saisons les joueurs de la cité royale
ont perdu sur la plus petite des marges
1 à 0 au classement les versets sont
toujours premier avec 18 points en sept
matches ils pourront se rattraper le
week end du 2 novembre à domicile contre
noisy l'eau du football encore avec le
championnat à 2 r2 ont joué ce week-end
la 5e journée trappe s'est incliné pour
la quatrième fois en cinq matchs cette
saison l'équipe coachée par ludovic que
gauthier a perdu sur son terrain face à
val d'europe 1 but à 0 au classement les
trappistes se sont 11e sur 12 équipes
engagées cette saison l'objectif du club
le maintien est pour l'instant compromis
grilles dorées merci michael je le
disais un ces résultats bien d'autres
encore à retrouver dans quelques
instants sur tv soixante dix huit dans
l'émission 7 8 sport on termine ce
journal avec une autre invité laurence
renard bonsoir vous êtes la présidente
de l'association la laine de paris si on
parle avec vous de cette unité de
transformation lainière qui est en train
de se monter à magny les hameaux
sous l'impulsion de votre association
une première assemblée générale s'est
tenue samedi à la laine de paris si
justement qui qui composent cette
association s'est composé d'artisans
lainiers et de bergers et de passionnés
de la laine donc c'est très ouvert
alors quand et pourquoi cette
association at elle été créée on a créé
l'association l'année dernière en
septembre 2018
ça vient y ait deux mouvements en
parallèle d'un bord des artisans qui
cherchait à avoir un ut travail plus
opérationnel et puis parallèlement le
parc naturel régional avait fait une
étude sur le potentiel lainiers en ile
de france et cette étude révélée un
potentiel sous-exploité puisque beaucoup
d'éleveurs ne valorise pas la laine
aujourd'hui le pnr de la haute vallée de
chevreuse ont précisé aux magny les
hameaux et est implantée alors les
objectifs du coup c'est de proposer
cette unité de transformation lainière
c'est ça exactement fait qu'elle dispose
d'un outil de travail
jeudi elle parce que c'est beaucoup de
femmes qui sont un tueur hier ou
tisserande ou créatrice de mode
voilà mais ça peut être aussi à des
bergers qui viendrait directement avec
leur laine du coup lavez la laine dans
un premier temps puis l'a gardée et le
cardage à l'intérêt d'être utilisés par
exemple dans les matelas ou ou d'être
transformé en fils alors notre unité
proposera pas d'unité de filage dans un
premier temps donc les radins
mutualisation pour aller jusqu en creuse
si on en reste si on va pas jusqu'au
film on peut faire du feutre donc il
peut être utilisé pour l'ameublement
pour les chapeaux pour les chaussures
les couvertures et il y aura une nuitée
de teinture naturelle avec des plantes
pour colorer tous ces différents
produits
cette filière laine dont vous parliez ce
qu'elle est bien implanté en île de
france et ce qu'elle est en
développement dans laquelle stade elle
se situe l état crée c'est à dire que la
grâce à l'association on a mis autour de
la table des bergers des artisans et ça
cette rencontre entre le nom de
l'agriculture et le monde de l'artisanat
n'avait pas eu lieu depuis très
longtemps sur le territoire donc non il
ya tout à créer organiser aussi des
tombes collectives pour aider les
éleveurs et puis se parler pour
augmenter la qualité de la laine enfin
retrouvé une qualité de l'air
intéressant parce que les éleveurs de
moutons il y en a beaucoup en ile de
france on connaît les moutons mérinos à
rambouillet il y en a beaucoup il de
francs alors du coup ça se développe
effectivement d'abord il ya des éleveurs
pour la viande qu'ils sont bien
emplettes implanté et puis il ya toutes
les pratiques déco pâturages pour
entretenir les espaces verts qui font
que le mouton a pris plus d'importance
ces dernières années et du coup plus de
moutons plus de l'aisne et du coup cette
unité sera implantée à magny les hameaux
c'est ça oui qui est en fait un peu
centrale par rapport à l'implantation
des différents éleveurs et des
différences d'artisans qui est pas trop
loin de la berge jury national non plus
qui est sûre territoire du parc naturel
et du parc naturel pardon et de terreau
et si tu es donc voila c'était 7 soutenu
très fortement par la municipalité qui
est derrière ce projet notamment
vous avez parlé de
de quoi sera constituée cette unité
comment elle sera construite je sais
aussi un intérêt 1
voilà comment dire un intérêt sur
l'écologie c'est ça oui le procédé déjà
se veut être écologiste c'est à dire les
techniques de lavage est économe en eau
il y aura pas de produits chimiques
utilisée pour laver cette eau dont
clergé seront propres
les plans tonnes seront des plantes
tinctoriales pour les teintures ya pas
de chimie et sur le bâtiment en fait on
ne parte partira de containers mis à
disposition par la mairie qu'on va
recycler en unités auto construite par
par l'association et je disais une
première assemblée générale qui s'est
tenue samedi à la ferme de closeraie là
où sera implantée cette future unité est
ce que c'est un projet qui intéresse est
ce que des habitants des riverains sont
venus les habitants passionnés par la
laine qui sont venus ou des bénévoles
qui vont qui nous accompagne sur la
construction du projet mais surtout ce
qui nous a fait vraiment plaisir c'est
qu'on était douze au départ et que l'avs
sont venus trois nouvelles personnes
pour utiliser cette unité une matelas
sierre un créateur de marque de
vêtements prêt-à-porter et une teinture
hier donc voilà on sent qu'il ya une
attente pour pouvoir utiliser cette
unité la concrètement dans duke est ce
qu'il reste à faire aujourd'hui alors il
ne reste à boucler le financement
puisque on a différents dossiers
certains sont valides et d'autres sont
en cours de d'attentes et
aujourd'hui-en-france moment il ya une
campagne de financement sur hello
assauts de financement participatif pour
nous aider enfin voila a bouclé ce
financement et après on vise
le camp ce moment de l'installation au
printemps 2020 on peut vous retrouvez
notamment sur deux pages instagram qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et on peut
retrouver facilement le lien lots assaut
il y à cette page
mais on va pascal sur le site et l'ol
sont au tap filière de l'aisne
ile-de-france normalement
on pouvoir on peut on peut retomber
facilement sur cette cagnotte merci
laurence renard merci d'être passé en
plateau présidente de cette association
à l'haleine de par ici voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
rendez vous dès demain à 18 heures pour
une nouvelle édition d'information
locale belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]